mom and dad are out on a date night
tonight how has it been with two in the
house now opposed and is rose being a
really good big sister yeah she's seven
so she's real she's very busy uh she's
yeah she's kind of like oh yeah he's
cute anyway so all this happened
non-stop talk and um yeah it's great i'm
you know i feel very fortunate that i've
been able to take this time to really
enjoy you know the early stages of my of
my motherhood uh with our son and it's
it's it's been wonderful i'm in a baby
bliss bubble so the american cinema tech
award is given to someone making a
significant contribution to motion
pictures so let's think about your body
of work for a second and i know you
probably have been thinking about this
knowing that you're going to get this
award but you and i spoke not too long
ago about some of the things that you've
done especially like being the first
avenger to executive produce their their
standalone film which was so great um so
when you think about everything i mean
has this all sunk in to you yet what's
happening tonight uh definitely not i
mean it does i've i've
you know it's it's a funny i feel like
in some way
i don't know it's the strength it's a
moment for me to kind of pause and take
it all in
um and
yeah just uh
you know i i i'm so in in it always that
i i don't really have the time to kind
of see
the whole body of work and you know i
in some ways when i was first told that
i was getting this award i was like what
wait is it over you know like i'm still
in the middle of my life my career but
it's it's a unique experience uh you
know and a very special one to be able
to
to to
just kind of take it all in and uh yeah
it's it's i'm very overwhelmed i know
when you think about it i and i'm going
to overwhelm you a little bit because
it's your night to get your flowers by
the way
you think about this and what they're
saying is you have a body of work
already that's going to outlive what you
do and leave your legacy and i know
that's probably i don't know if you
think about that often but you know have
you thought about the fact that damn i
kind of been killing the game for almost
30 years now um i mean i really kind of
i've been sort of on my path and uh
you know i i love my job now more than i
ever have before and i think i'm very
much focused on
being
better getting better and getting more
efficient and
understanding you know my
the parts of me that are uncomfortable
to explore and what you know being
curious about those those places and um
using that in my work and i think i'm
i'm very much in the middle of it and so
i i haven't been able to really think
about what the legacy means because it's
it's i'm just too entrenched in the work
right now but it's not just also the
movies that you make because you've also
made a you know a dent in this industry
by using your voice and especially when
you think about what you've been doing
lately when it comes to what people
should be paid for theatrical versus
streaming and and how you you lost you
use your voice for for other actors not
just yourself but so are you happy with
kind of how that
you know settled out
definitely i mean um you know i think
it's
it's a kind of whole new world and
there's gonna be bumps in the road and
um
you know i feel very fortunate enough
that i'm someone who
you know can take a stand and um you
know i'm happy to shoulder that burden
and uh you know i'm happy to know that
other actors other creatives will not
have to deal with with that in moving
forward in the future and uh yeah i'm
i'm happy to continue continue my work
well the mcu loves you for sure because
i don't know if you know but there's a
real nice nod to you in hawkeye had you
heard about that no don't tell me okay
okay i'm not gonna tell you okay you get
you gotta watch though because there's a
very nice nod to you say anything okay i
won't say i won't say anything
you